nonconformity within these groups often
tends to be very dangerous so
individuals that stand out within the
group are often those that are taken by
the predator so there's a strong
selection pressure not only to look like
the other individuals in the group but
also to behave like other individuals in
the group and also if one were to
consider a predator sort of attacking a
fish school or a bird flock you know the
reason that the concerted motion these
waves work so effectively is because
everyone is essentially following a
similar type of rule if you try to do
something completely different you could
of course cause congestion you could
cause a pileup within these groups and
that would of course be selected out of
the out of the population and so
individuals that follow such rules tend
not to last very long
so in you know in a wide range of
scenarios there is a a risk that animals
face by copying the behavior of each
other they risk a sort of a cascade of
of misinformation and this is actually a
kin to what happens sometimes in human
societies when people start believing
something without actually checking it
out themselves so if the decision
depends on on that made by a few
individuals at the start of the process
then everyone then joins in and decides
that they agree with that without
actually having assessed the information
directly themselves then this can lead
to the sort of auto catalysis in the
spread of maladaptive information now
what we find in animals is that they're
the way that they interact with each
other is tuned to minimize this risk but
you know there's a compromise as well
because it does sometimes happen that
they do make mistakes of course because
if you really were to sort of look at
all of the information and assess it it
that takes time and time is precious and
so just like you know a human when
you're looking for say an insurance
policy or whatever you don't actually
read all of the details all of the fine
print of all of the alternatives you
tend to look online and perhaps believe
what google tells you or perhaps you ask
a few friends who you trust and then you
rely on that information and so we know
we also have this type of positive
feedback so our decision-making as well
as is influenced by these social
processes
it is of course a myth the lemmings
don't actually hurl themselves off off
cliffs you know these animals are highly
susceptible to population fluctuations
and so the predators tend to sort of
increase in number and then the rodents
can increase in number and so on and so
you this can actually lead to vast
fluctuations so one year there may be
many many individuals are the years very
few and also I can't remember the exact
example the lemmings but there's huge
potential in these populations for mass
migration for individuals to migrate on
mass and you know even in north america
the the squirrel that we see everywhere
the grey squirrel used to once upon a
time not that longer a few hundred years
ago used to form mass migrations as far
as you could see there are descriptions
of squirrels and they when they come to
rivers they all swim across the rivers
and people would go out with you know
guns and dogs and you know I just it was
a phenomenon and you know also there's
an extinct birds now called the the
passenger pigeon which also used to live
in the United States and when these
flocks were so dense during their
migrations that the sky would go black
you know and and these of course have
been the passenger pigeons have been
wiped out by it by man and the squirrels
environment is now so fragmented the
forests are so fragmented that no longer
do they form these mass migrations but
this kind of collective behaviors are
actually ubiquitous you know at all
scales from no bacterial colonies to to
you know very large aggregates like
locusts that we study which are some of
the largest groups on the planet